-Performing "Someday"
from their new album "Human,"
here is OneRepublic!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ Some days
I'm treading the water ♪
♪ And feel like
it's getting deep ♪
♪ Some nights I drown in
the weight of the things ♪
♪ That I think I need ♪
♪ Sometimes I feel ♪
♪ Incomplete ♪
♪ Yeah ♪
♪ But you always say ♪
♪ To me ♪
♪ Say to me ♪
♪ Oh, you say,
"Someday when we're older ♪
♪ We'll be shinin'
like we're gold" ♪
♪ Yeah, won't we? ♪
-♪ Won't we? ♪
-♪ And someday
when we're older ♪
♪ I'll be yours
and you'll be mine, be happy ♪
♪ Happy ♪
♪ Oh, you say,
"Someday when we're older ♪
♪ We won't worry 'bout the
things that we don't need" ♪
♪ We don't need ♪
♪ 'Cause one day down the line ♪
♪ Before we both
run out of time ♪
♪ We're gonna see ♪
♪ That someday we'll be
all that we need ♪
♪♪
♪ Someday we'll be
all that we need ♪
♪♪
♪ Oh ♪
♪ Been the best,
been the worst ♪
♪ Been a ghost in
a crowded room ♪
-♪ Oh,
yeah-yeah-yeah-yeah-yeah ♪
-♪ I took a chance, took a turn,
took a dive ♪
♪ And it led to you ♪
-♪ Oh,
yeah-yeah-yeah-yeah-yeah ♪
-♪ So many times that I wish
we could be anywhere but here ♪
♪ So many times that I wish ♪
♪ I could see what you see
so clear ♪
♪ So clear ♪
♪ Oh, you say,
"Someday when we're older ♪
♪ We'll be shinin'
like we're gold" ♪
♪ Yeah, won't we? ♪
-♪ Won't we? ♪
-♪ You say,
"Someday when we're older ♪
♪ I'll be yours
and you'll be mine, be happy" ♪
♪ Happy ♪
♪ Oh, you say,
"Someday when we're older ♪
♪ We won't worry 'bout the
things that we don't need" ♪
♪ We don't need ♪
♪ One day down the line
before we both run out of time ♪
♪ You're gonna see ♪
♪ That someday we'll be
all that we need ♪
♪♪
♪ Someday we'll be
all that we need ♪
♪♪
♪ Oh, we need ♪
♪ Someday ♪
♪ Someday when we're older ♪
♪ We'll be shinin'
like we're gold ♪
♪ Yeah, won't we? ♪
♪ Won't we? ♪
♪ Someday down the line
before we both run out of time ♪
♪ You're gonna see ♪
♪ That someday we'll be
all that we need ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]